good morning John it's my last
Fitzsimmons video I can't it went so
fast though it was a very long couple of
weeks and at happy times and sad times
and reunion videos and charity galas and
now I'm in New Hampshire
visiting family and I want to be clear
that this is an unusual level of weird
however I would be lying if I said that
my life hasn't gotten really weird and
really cool and really wonderful and
really complicated over the last eight
or nine years of us making vlogbrothers
videos my life is not normal I don't
think any lives are normal but my life
is clearly not normal and I am a number
of things that I was not in back in 2006
I am professionally respected i fairly
well known and thus one might say that i
am a success everything's people have
started to say this to me that like
what's it like to be successful or
congratulations on your success I have
felt really weird about it like troubled
by it I was having a hard time figuring
out exactly why I was feeling this way
like is it modesty is it false modesty
maybe a bit of both of those but after
think about this for a while here's what
it actually is I feel like when someone
says congratulations on your success
they're putting you into a category of
people that that is extremely difficult
to achieve that only a very small
percentage of humans on the planet could
ever achieve and then saying that that
is a thing that all people should strive
for despite the fact that the only way
that something like this can happen to
you is you happen to stumble across a
great big pile of steaming luck and then
fall into it and get it stuck all over
your body and just like I can't get this
luck off of me like there isn't enough
space in human brains for everyone to be
known by a large number of people and
that's what Fame is weirdly it's just
the ability to have your face recognized
by a larger than average number of
people yeah look I'm very happy I'm a
happy person but I was happy before I
was successful like I was happy in 2006
had great friends in great family and I
was working on interesting projects and
I have learned a lot of things and I was
excited to learn more and I don't think
that most people would even argue that
success is a necessary part of happiness
but I think we do conflate those two
things whenever I'm told that I'm
successful I worry about what that word
means to the person saying it and what
it means to society like does it mean
achieving the things you want to achieve
which is the good definition like I want
to do things and then I did do those
thing
and thus I am a success I have succeeded
or is it achieving something that most
people implicitly cannot achieve it is
impossible for most people to have
because it's based on the scarcity of
resources it's based on the fact that
not everyone can be famous it's based on
the fact that not everyone can be in the
top 20% of incomes being successful
being richer or more powerful or more
well-known than most people that kind of
societally recognized implicit success
is something that I think we all crave
and it's something that I have to some
extent but I don't think it's something
that I need to feel valued and valuable
and it's not something that I it's
definitely not something I need to feel
happy I think that it is very societally
important that we figure out ways to
value ourselves and value each other
that don't have anything to do with
scarcity you know the scarcity of money
the scarcity of fame the scarcity of
power even I would much rather be and
much rather associate myself with the
kind of people who want to have positive
impact on a small number of people than
to collect a great deal of wealth and
power even at the expense of other
people so John as I finish off my final
piece in this video of 2015 I don't know
what success is I still don't I know
what successes are individual things but
the the acquisition of success in and
being a success I think that's kind of a
made-up thing but I am very grateful
what I'm grateful for is having great
friends and great family and a great
community who make me feel valued who
make me question myself and question my
beliefs and challenge me to do
interesting and difficult things and to
become a better person John I'll see you
on Tuesday or no Friday I'll see you
tomorrow which means yes we only have
one day left a pizza miss one day left
for to get the shirts and the other
products at dftba.com and thank you to
everybody for a really great pizza mess